hi I'm Erik Bosse and Star Wars last
Jedi has been out for a little while now
and after diving super deep into the
movies visuals and Easter eggs might
break down upon re-watching the film I
realize there are even more nerdy french
fries at the bottom of this bag some fun
details me editing some interesting
background on these characters in their
designs trivia you can use to win over
your nephews when you watch Star Wars
with them or in my case make them say oh
god Erik find the new hottie spoilers
head for the last Jedi and again make
sure to check out my breakdown for all
the big stuff you might have missed
including all the references to past
Star Wars films what's to deal with
those Jedi books clues that explain how
Leia was able to survive in space and
Luke's force projection house no explain
hints at his origin it's always in the
blame people okay here we go starting
with this opening space battle of Dakar
the resistance a wing pilot tally lynch
era has the or Abeche letters da written
on the side of her helmet though stand
for deadly approach which according to
the film's visual dictionary is a punch
line to a well known pilots joke don't
ask me what the setup of that joke is
hopefully it doesn't have anything to do
with Biggs Darklighter because that
would be too soon speaking of fallen
pilots from the Battle of Yavin this
battle features the death of a pilot
known as Jay Chris Tubbs who seems like
a nod to Porkins from that battle moving
on
to Luke Skywalker and Ray on atch 2 now
in order to pull off Luke's haunted
reclusion Mark Hamill said that he
invented a super dark backstory for the
character now it's not officially part
of Luke's backstory it was just for
Hamill to emotionally prepare himself
basically his idea was that Luke had
fallen in love with the widow with a
young child and he left the Jedi Order
to marry her and raise this kid but then
the child got a hold of his lightsaber
and accidentally killed himself
yikes Hamill said that he was inspired
by real-life tragedies of gun violence
and accidents involving children saying
that he needed to go to really dark
places to get where Luke needed to be
for this story so knowing that this is
what was running through Hamill's mind
his reluctance to work with Rey comes
from a very real place meanwhile good
luck laughing at Luke tossing his
lightsaber ever again for a less
depressing detail many of the wide shots
of the island feature pork's flying
around now we learned that those pork's
were inspired by the real-life puffins
birds that inhabit the island of skellig
michael but actually those puffins
worthy
season the porks had to be invented in
the first place when the crew began
filming the movie those seasonal birds
kept flying into the background of the
shots so rather than having to CGI those
birds out of every frame they decided to
instead create new flying species native
to this location to justify why we see
these blurry things flapping around the
cliffs and the wide shots now one of my
favorite details in the last Jedi
involves the new hyperspace tracking
technology that factors so heavily in a
plot according to the visual dictionary
the first order had picked up research
on this technology after it began in a
secret Imperial think tank called the
Tarkin initiative of course it's named
after Grand Moff Tarkin Imperial
commander of the Death Star we actually
saw evidence of this research in a super
Sneaky easter egg back in rogue one when
jyn erso and casseon and/or go through
the Imperial archives on the base on
scare if notice one of the files that
gen reads off now gen I know those Death
Star schematics were the bigger fish to
fry but it wouldn't have heard to tip
off the rebels at Turkey and also had
hyperspace tracking in the works just
saying also the film made a big deal out
of roast Tico's hazy and smelts
medallion the second half of which was
carried by her sister the Bombardier
Paige who died in the opening battle
that medallion actually has some even
deeper roots for Rose its shape shows
haze minor the sisters home planet which
was a mining planet the metal comes from
one of those mines Hayes miner was
located outside the Republic's
jurisdiction so it was an early target
for the first order to test its weapons
on the population and then steal their
children to raise as stormtroopers
so for Rose and Paige this medallion
isn't just a reminder of home it's a
reminder of the horrible war crimes the
first-order committed against their
people moving on to Rey practicing with
Luke's lightsaber now if you watch this
scene closely as Luke watches on from
afar Rey senses him and for a split
second you can see her quickly look back
at him and that is what causes her to
lose her focus to slice the boulder so
really this wasn't that she was sloppy
with her sword work or too much of a
rookie this is just another example
their relationship how she's nervous
over this legendary Jedi Master taking
interest in her skills I'm not sure if
it was intentional but this moment
definitely feels parallel to the opening
scene of the movie whiplash when the
nervous student was rehearsing and
seemingly alone
but then slipped up when he looked up
suddenly to realize he was being watched
by this reclusive crabby guru checking
in on canto bites some of you had
questions on why Benicio Del Toro's
character DJ was even in the jail cell
to begin with especially considering he
could break out so easily it turns out
DJ got arrested for a petty crime on
purpose just so he could have a place to
sleep without that canto bite police
department bothering him further he does
one at a place for the night and he had
no intention of sticking around when
they use the father's to break out of a
casino you may have caught this bulbous
opera singer her name is habla mold bro
sounds like someone trying to pick out a
brand of cigarettes with her mouth full
Oh blow mold bro and fun fact about her
that freaky cleavage that covers her
body is actually an engorged egg sac
which she shows off because she's eager
to find a hatching partner moving on to
the return of Captain phasma in this
movie she now brandishes a new weapon
this collapsible Quicksilver baton now
although it resembles the weapon from
the red Imperial Guards in the original
trilogy it actually comes from her own
harsh home world of Parnassus this
actually brings up a very interesting
part of her backstory so fast I came to
join the first order when Huck's his
father Brenda Lux crash-landed on
Parnassus and they're recruited her
Brenda Lux was really the architect of
the whole first order and the ship that
he crashed landed on was a Naboo Cruiser
that used to belong to Emperor Palpatine
phasma actually repurposed that shiny
chromium hull to form her armor later on
phasma and Huck's his son the Huck's we
know Armitage Huck's would conspire to
assassinate Brendel using the poison of
a beetle from Parnassus which was
untraceable it was this secret murder
that led to Armitage Huck's and phasma's
meteoric rise within the first-order
ranks okay let's look at snoke's
Praetorian guards one detail i noticed
while rewatching is that there are
precisely eight of them four sets of two
pairs they're designed this way to be
symmetric to reflect the first orders
motto of what is past is future so there
are really four sets with an identical
pair that carries one of the four melee
weapons that we see and this sets up
some amazing visual symmetry when kylo
and rey split up the pair's standing
back-to-back to take on each half there
was also some really interesting design
that went into the execution or
stormtroopers and phasma orders to kill
Finn and rose their laser axes are meant
to resemble a medieval
headsman axe and their helmets have a
black design kind of like the black
hoods worn by those headsman and
cultural depictions by the way that
actually wasn't the case in real life
history it's a Hollywood thing but in
myth and stories they wore those masks
to hide their identity so that they
didn't have to feel personally
responsible for the death of the
condemned additionally these
executioner's stormtroopers armor masks
their serial numbers unlike their normal
armor and their helmets contain ways to
disguise their voices and then a little
detail I liked when all hell breaks
loose on the supremacy
when bb-8 operates the chicken walker or
a TST the hood of it remains tethered in
the hangar and then it pops off when he
moves forward swinging back kind of like
a wrecking ball to take out a storm
troopers firing on them from behind
later in the film during the battle of
kraid the first-order uses this super
laser siege cannon to blast through the
door the base now you may have noticed
its design resembles the focus lens of
the Death Star that's because it's the
exact same technology it's powered by
the same composite Kyber crystals that
power the Death Star as well as
lightsabers and one final additional
detail I noticed at the end of the film
when Rey greets bb-8 she complements the
droid on its new antenna that's a
callback to their first encounter in the
force awakens when she rescued bb-8 and
straightened out its bent antenna a
question for you guys since I've seen
this movie at least like 10 times at
this point for those of you who have
watched the movie what about the last
Jedi has changed for you
were there any scenes or plot points
that you found better this time around
or did some seem a bit more
disappointing for me the first time I
watched the movie Laura Dern's Vice
Admiral hold oh really got on my nerves
I didn't know why she was acting the way
she was acting but I got to say every
time ivory watched the movie I've liked
her a lot more and honestly Poe Dameron
scene is a bit more of a jerk that's
just me though I want to know your
thoughts comment with your answers down
below or tweet me directly I da boss and
follow new rockstars on Twitter at new
rockstars for updates on her videos like
this video and subscribe to new
rockstars for more Star Wars coverage
including deep dives into the last Jedi
and all the details about the upcoming
solo a Star Wars story and if you really
like us you can contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our donors
especially Kristina Armstrong thanks for
watching guys bye